this has been an incredible experience
for me it's the first wave I've been to
and I've been struck by I think three
things that have really made an
impression the first is the passionate
commitment to the people in response to
the Arab Spring as it's been called all
the change that's taken place and the
pace of their change so much change has
happened and it's happened so quickly
and the role that young people have paid
in that change that they have actually
been the driving force that they've in
the words of the transitional leader of
the Libyan government of the
transitional Libyan government in his
words that they the young people of
Libya actually drove their change so the
Arab Spring has really been driven by
young people and I think the other thing
that has really struck me is the
opportunities that are going to be
created as a result of this these young
people want things to happen they want
the change to ultimately lead to better
lifestyles more jobs and for them to
really express themselves in political
terms democratically and in economic
terms democratically and I think this
this conference for me leave me with an
abiding sense of optimism I think that
there's much change tool to happen but I
feel that the process has been started
it's an irreversible process that's
going to continue and i think that the
Arab people across the board those
people that have not experienced changed
yet world and i think that the region
will be all the better for it in the
gulf in north africa right throughout
the MENA region